this is life in beijing now it happens
to everyone around it happened to me
this morning i went to the gym uh did a
class and then i came out the doors were
shut the fire exits were actually locked
and people saying we had to stay there
until the afternoon we had a bit of
negotiation we did get out and that was
quite a lucky escape because you just
don't know what's going to happen
whether you're going to stay there
whether you're going to be taken to
quarantine a colleague here our asia
producer leo he was kept in his house
for more than 24 hours while they
investigated the case and again that's
lucky we haven't been sent to the
quarantine centers it seems pretty
extraordinary in 2022 this is still
happening and beijing has been battling
this outbreak for a long time since
early april it had a lockdown for five
weeks where pretty much everything in
the city was shot it lifted those
restrictions
but then just a couple of days later
later one individual he went to a
nightclub actually onto very very few
nightclubs and became a super spreader
account uh event now responsible for
more than 200 cases so authorities are
playing this game of whack-a-mole this
uncertainty still persists and there's
no end to it in sight china has this
zero covered policy and it's not unique
in that australia had a zero-covered
policy south korea taiwan all had zero
kobe policies but as vaccines have
become available as the population has
become vaccinated they have lifted
restrictions to try and live with the
virus china says that is lying flat as
it puts it and it says that doing the
same would overwhelm its health system
so for right now this sort of very
uncertain very stressful existence is
likely to can you continue both in
beijing and other cities around china